okay so jordan peele's knope is now out
digitally and i thought we'd do a big
breakdown on the film to discuss all the
hidden details easter eggs and things
you missed in it the movie centers
around the haywards trying to prove that
there's an alien spacecraft visiting
their farm but they unearth something
much much weirder now the movie is based
loosely on the legends of skinwalker
ranch which is a hot site for paranormal
activity over the decades several ufos
have been said to have visited the
location but the movie changes things up
to make the creature a living uap that
feeds on horses and humans just in the
same way that peel laced a lot of
imagery throughout get out and us like
this look look they're wearing a us flag
nope has a lot of subliminal stuff too
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking it all down but if this is your
first time here welcome to the heavy
spoilers show i'm your host paul aka the
guy whose theories make you go nope now
let's get into the video
[Music]
now one of my favorite subliminal images
in the movie happens when we go and
visit the set at gordy's home we slowly
purvey all the wreckage and destruction
and can see panavision cameras tilted as
we approach the set later on at
jupiter's claim we see that juba's
selling alien toys and masks which have
head shapes similar to the tops of the
cameras if you think that's a reach then
it's also important to bear in mind that
these masks are also used by his kids to
try and frighten the haywards what you
might not have noticed though is that
they're also wearing monkey costumes
calling back to gordy's cameras of
course appear throughout the movie and
there's constant talks about the oprah
shot the impossible shot and so on and
so forth now we see as the hayward set
up cameras around their home and
throughout the movie we very much get a
history of the device with us going
through several digital film and analog
models elements of jean jacket are also
based on a camera and after the title
card pops up we travel through what we
learn as its mouth this is built to look
like one of the first ever cameras
created and as we go through the passage
we see the first ever motion picture the
movie tells us that the haywards are
actually descendants of this man who
also just so happens to be riding on the
back of a horse whereas the person who
filmed this event has had his names put
in the annals of history the writer is
often overlooked and i feel this film is
very much about how hollywood chews
people up and then spits them out jean
jacket itself actually chews people up
and spits them out possibly carrying on
this theme now the name of the writer is
completely made up because we don't
actually know it in real life tying back
to this idea i actually have a theory
that the haywards wouldn't even get the
fame and fortune that they were seeking
in the end because all that would get
focused on is the alien over them you
also see several news crews show up
who'd probably report this story before
they even had the chance to sell it
keith david's character otis is a great
example of someone being chewed up and
spit out and after he's killed by a
falling coin we later learned this was
caused by jean jacket writing down
debris after a meal we discover his
proudest moment was working on the
scorpion king which we see stills from
and the logo for it appears on the
hoodie that oj wears at the end
unfortunately we find out that they
replaced the horses with camels so all
of otis work kinda went to waste now oj
ends up riding a horse with a series of
flags coming from it and this is similar
to the decoy that jean jacket ate
earlier in the movie it ends up being
unable to digest this and it could
possibly show why it avoids eating him
and the horse later on either way i feel
like this movie is a metaphor for how
hollywood treats people and it can be
used on a number of things like animals
actors horse wranglers set crew and just
a manner of those in the hollywood
machine now the name oj is also likely a
reference to oj simpson which is teased
at during the scene on set and heywood
could be riffing on hollywood there's
also a great moment where oj is fired
from set after his horse is deemed to be
too dangerous we can actually catch a
vfx one being wheeled in that's gonna
replace the animal a gordy's attack is a
complete disaster and it's set off by
the bursting of some balloons for the
character's birthday this idea of
balloons popping is very important as
it's also the way that jean jacket is
killed in the final few scenes now we
actually got some balloons recently for
our kids and the dog does not like them
at all so if i get eaten by a cavapoo
then you know what happened now dupe
ends up surviving this attack because he
doesn't look gaudy directly in his eyes
but the majority of it he's staring at
the floor and when the monkey eventually
comes face to face with him he looks at
it through a veil rather than having
direct eye contact throughout most of
the attack jube is staring at his shoe
and this is facing upwards at an almost
impossible angle this metaphorically
ties in with the idea of a bad miracle
which is something that oj and emerald
later discuss on the farm they talk
about how the uap is a bad miracle
because obviously it's something that
seems impossible but it's also brought
tragedy and terror with it their father
was killed and it's now stalking the
form leading to this miraculous thing
being very negative it's the same with
the shoe during the rampage and though
it seems like something incredible it's
happening in the midst of this vicious
monkey attack now being this close to
death with an animal that still ends up
fist bumping him is likely why dupe
believes that he can also tame jean
jacket the fist bump could even be a
reference to the name of peel's
production company monkey paw which we
see pop up in the titles either way the
movie hammers home the idea time and
time again that wild animals can't be
fully tamed and this is seen at numerous
points there's of course the horse on
set that ends up kicking the bucket
which is that foreshadowing at kicking
the book never mind and there's also the
original jean jacket which emerald
couldn't tame tube of course fails to
control the uap however he still
believes that he can turn something wild
into entertainment calling back to
gordy's home tube actually keeps a
shrine for this which we visit out the
back of his office and you might also
notice that he has the scissors from us
on his desk this calls back to peel's
prior work and it's such a great
inclusion in the film now that movie is
also lit with a palindrome 1111 which
refers to bible verses figures and also
reflections this number also appears on
angel's van who we'll talk more about in
just a bit hajipa also has the shoe in
his secret room and later on we see
another item of clothing that he's made
for the arrival of jean jacket in what's
an awesome bit of costume design you can
actually see that the back of his jacket
has a ufo with a beam firing out of it i
kind of hope this jacket is a jean
jacket and if it is then that's one of
the best easter eggs that i've ever seen
the room also has the intro for gordy's
home playing on a screen jordan peel
actually released this full clip on
twitter and it has clips in it from cape
canaveral due to the dad being an
astronaut this tragically was the launch
side of the space shuttle challenger
which exploded killing all on board this
was an overwhelmingly tragic event that
was widely publicized similar to gordy's
attack on tv a gordy's attack very much
acts as a cautionary tale that dupe
doesn't learn from and it's clear that
he tried to profit from the tragedy a
couple paid him fifty thousand dollars
to spend a night in the hidden museum
and his actions with jean jacket cement
that it wasn't really something that
swayed him away from causing a spectacle
for prophet's sake the movie even opens
with a quote discussing spectacles in
general and this comes from the old
testament the idea of profit of course
can be represented through money and
there might be some irony in the fact
that otis took to selling horses and he
was killed by a coin it's even possible
that duke didn't learn from this because
he repressed the entire event when
talking about it he tells the story
through what happened on an snl sketch
rather than what he saw with his own
eyes this might have even replaced his
entire recollection of the events which
is why he talks about the sketch rather
than the horror he witnessed a huge
shout out to new rockstars are pointing
out that this might be a nod to an snl
sketch called papa's peepers which was
about a human monkey that went ape
now there's also another couple of cool
details in the office meeting oj asks
dupe if it's possible to buy back his
horses but he seems a bit cagey over
this he of course couldn't sell them
back why because he'd been feeding them
to jean jacket so this is why he tries
to change the deal as quickly as
possible he also hints towards wanting
to buy the haywood ranch and we learn
that this is to expand jupiter's claim
as the creature lives in a cloud located
just above it this would give him better
access to the beast and he could build
an entire live show around it now peel
actually told entertainment weekly that
jupiter's claim has some symbolism to it
he said it's very much about how
hollywood has made this big mythology
out of the wild wild west he stated that
movies have somewhat sanitized the time
period and that it's not only erased the
black cowboy but that it's also toned
down how brutal over time that it was i
believe this also ties in with the kids
sheriff poster that we see and it shows
how dupe has very much played to the
simplified version of the time period
and whether it's that gordy's home or
whatever it's all highly sanitized
throughout every hollywood depiction
however peel plays some black cowboy
movie posters throughout the hayward
home hinting at the legacy that's often
forgotten about peel purposely put in a
post of a buck in the preacher which he
said was the first film he watched that
acknowledged a black cowboy but the live
show is a complete bloodbath and it's
horrifying watching the onlookers travel
through jean jacket's digestive system
the attack actually happens at 6 13 and
coincidentally gordy's attack ended up
lasting 6 minutes and 13 seconds duke
clearly picked this time for that very
reason showing how his entire fate was
attached to that and we see one of his
co-stars there who had her face mauled
by gori and can catch that she's wearing
a valen hat this is likely a naughty
charlenash who was attacked by a
chimpanzee that also just happened to be
an animal actor as well she appeared on
the oprah winfrey show talking about the
entire ordeal wearing a similar veil to
what mary jo elliott shows up in now you
might also pick up on that being a pig
that survived this encounter and that's
because it's physically impossible for a
pig to look upwards yet it's not like
the dog thing and shauna the dead pigs
genuinely can't turn their heads towards
the sky now the movie has obvious
references to steven spielberg's films
and this includes jaws in which both the
shark and jean jacket are killed by
pressurized air explosions there's also
a nod to close encounters i'm sure that
the noise that jean jacket makes is
pulling notes from the ship
[Music]
i also feel like there's lots of nodes
to war of the worlds namely with the
raining blood falling on the farmhouse
this was something that appeared in the
original work and also spielberg's
adaptation starring tom cruise appeal
also stated that he was inspired by king
kong which two centers around humans
attempting to catch a wild animal so
that they can put it on display for
profit i might be reaching here which i
often do but it's likely that peel also
referenced his favorite movie aka the
shining get out featured a ton of
callbacks to it and the director said
that it's massively influenced how he
makes movies the trailer for the film
actually had the title descending down
and this was similar to the way that the
credits moved in that film on top of
that every single chapter that appeared
in that movie started off with a title
called denoting the days the appeal does
something similar but the title cards
are all names of animals that appear in
the movie now one thing that you might
not have noticed though is that every
single animal name that appears then
leads to the death of said animal in
that exact scene our angel is also a
very interesting character and he ends
up coming from the ill-fated fry's
electronics store that now is out of
business each fry had its own theme to
it with every store being set up in a
specific way this fry's theme is
coincidentally ufos which is why we see
a big spaceship model sticking out of
the entrance a huge hit out to teen
vogue for pointing out that he might
actually represent being a guardian
angel for the pair as they try and
navigate this miracle he constantly
watches over them gives them support and
even a safe haven in his apartment after
they leave the ranch he also wears a
shirt that says earth on it with an
image of the cosmos possibly tying him
with this idea now he's the one who
brings up the term uap and this is a
real world phrase that was only coined
recently the pentagon released a
statement saying they were examining
this unexplained aerial phenomena and in
official circles it's replaced the term
ufo it's even possible that nope stands
for another planet earth but let me know
below exactly what you think now he also
talks about the ancient aliens
documentary on the history channel which
yeah aliens other great details include
how emerald messes up the amount of
greats when discussing her ancestor on
the horse we hear a recording in which
otis drops his speech word for word
later on and it's clear she's memorized
this which is why she's missing the
extra great now we also see the director
antlers looking over footage of
predators likely tying into this idea of
attempting to tame them there's also
lots of shots of animal eyes and this
connects to the idea of avoiding eye
contact in order to navigate jean jacket
and a lot of predators i kind of feel
like that ties into the sunglasses at
night song which is also played in
angel's van that's about a guy who wears
his sunglasses at night and this would
stop someone seeing directly into his
eyes now oj brings up the navy ufo clip
which he saw online and this is a
reference to the fuzzy footage that was
declassified in 2021 now the tmz
reporter that shows up actually has a
cool little detail attached to them his
name is ryder my brage and the name my
bridge belonged to the man who filmed
the rider on the back of the horse he
captured the first ever motion picture
and was world renowned whilst the rider
wasn't so essentially the tmz guy was
gonna cash in and be remembered rather
than the haywards just like their great
grandpa it's a great it's a great great
uh great grandpa no anyway lastly we see
emerald doing akira slide on the
motorbike which peelers said is one of
his favorite movies he actually was
offered the chance to direct it but he
turned it down because you don't with a
classic now emerald leads it to the well
and this of course was foreshadowed by
the kids sheriff poster which it pulled
from very obvious easter egg and the
perfect way to end the video which i
hope you've enjoyed huge thank you for
checking it out don't forget to
subscribe and please hit the thumbs up
button as it massively helps us out
without the way thanks for sitting until
the end i've been paul you've been the
best i'll see on the next one take care
peace